Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
It looks like
Marvel is finally bringing ghost rider
to the MCU as we're heading
towards Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty.
Avengers 6 Secret Wars and this big soft-reboot that they're going to pull
before we start doing all these X-Men
and mutant related movies.
there have been a ton,
a ton of Ghost Rider
Easter eggs through the past few years
and Marvel phase four.
There will be more in
some of the upcoming movies and TV shows.
So we'll break it all down.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I know everyone wants to see Marvel,
Midnight Suns team up in the MCU.
Introducing a version of Ghost Rider
is just the next step on that path,
But there are a couple of ways
that they're making that happen
probably the biggest news
this past week is that Nicolas Cage
is supposed to be coming back
as his Johnny Blaze Ghost Rider.
And it looks like it's going to be part
of Deadpool three with all the multiverse
hopping that Deadpool and Wolverine
are going to be doing.
most of the websites that are reporting
this don't specify
whether or not Ghost Rider
is going to appear in the 838 universe
since it sounds like most of the movie
will take place on that earth.
With a few exceptions,
The movie is going to deal
with the aftermath of what happened
with Scarlet Witch after Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
They basically turn that universe
in that movie to a more comic book
accurate place with everyone based
either on the X-Men
Animated Series
versions of the characters, or ones
that were just much closer to Marvel
comic book versions of the characters.
That's how they're explaining Wolverine's
yellow suit from the comics.
You have Patrick
Stewart's Professor X in the yellow chair
from the animated series.
All the other X-Men are coming back
like Jean Gray, Storm, Cyclops, Ian
McKellen's, Magneto,
are all supposed to be wearing similar
comic book accurate suits,
and since there's supposed to be
so many different cameos from Fox Marvel
characters like Ben Affleck's daredevil,
Jennifer Garner's
electro of all people, even
Channing Tatum's almost version of Gambit,
because they kind of canceled his movie
before it actually wound up getting made
It makes sense that you get Nicolas Cage
to come back for a cameo
as his Ghost Rider because he's the legacy
version of that character.
In Kevin Fog,
he plans on recasting, doing something
totally new with Ghost Writer in future
MCU movies.
the only difference between the ghost
writer movies in the Fox Marvel movies
because we're doing a lot of Fox
Marvel stuff and Deadpool three
like X-Men, Fantastic Four is that Sony
released the original Ghost Rider
movies, not Fox,
but you have a lot of Tobey Maguire,
Andrew Garfield stuff
happening in Secret Wars,
so it makes sense
that they're doing a lot of legacy
Sony stuff to
but you get the idea of the legacy version
of the Ghost Rider character coming back
for one last hurrah before they do
something different with the character.
He even just came back during the Flash
movie as it's almost version of Superman
because kind of like a Channing Tatum
gambit situation.
They never wound up making his movie.
They just got really close to
making his Superman movie back in the day.
Nicolas Cage is also a huge, a huge comic
book nerd for his entire life.
So he loves doing stuff like this.
So he probably pretty quick to come back
anyway, unless you count agents of SHIELD
Ghost Rider as already
being canon to the MCU, this would be like
the first real appearance
of a ghost writer in the MCU.
Agents of SHIELD
is mostly canon to the MCU.
So you can argue either way
that he's already Canon,
but then you run into some multiverse
problems
with the darkhold
because there were two different versions
of the official MCU canon version
that we saw during Wandavision in Doctor
Strange.
Multiverse of Madness
is totally different from the agents
of SHIELD version of the Darkhold
But you can see the Kevin Varga
has been trying to do Ghost Rider stuff,
setting it up in the background
with a bunch of Easter eggs.
In a lot of previous movies,
there have been a ton of Ghost Rider
Easter eggs and references
during Marvel Phase four, probably
the biggest ones were during She-Hulk
and Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
most of the She-Hulk ones
were during episode four.
The episode was called
Is This Not Real Magic, which is a
reference to Wong suing the magician,
pretending to be a full blown sorcerer.
turns out there was a student cum artist
but was just a total dirtbag.
And they kicked him out after a week
and he stole a ceiling ring and he's
been causing trouble at his magic venue
ever since.
Using the most Ghost Rider name
he could possibly think of.
The showrunner actually explained
what was going on
with the Ghost Rider name
because he's calling himself Donnie Blaze.
Obviously that's meant to be a reference
to Johnny Blaze.
the fire dimension that he keeps sending
people to is supposed to be a reference
to Marvel's version of Hell.
they're couple of different dimensions
in the MCU
that you could call hell just in general,
like they're called the Hell Lords.
in. They're couple of major characters
that you associate with that
like you can make all the Mephisto jokes
that you want.
Madison keeps talking about a demon
that she made a contract with
like she sold her
soul to be sent back home.
that's what they basically show
during the post-credits
scenes like her signing her soul away.
I give a couple drops in my blood, sign
the contract that they sent me back.
I'm not allowed to talk about it,
the ghost looking demon is another
reference to a version of the devil.
Like it's a form that the devil takes,
but the name tag on it.
This says Jake in the end credits scene
is depicted as if it's drawn by the court.
Art is based on what Madison told them.
So it's like his account
of what Madison remembered kind of wrong.
So the Demons name probably wasn't Jake,
I couldn't actually find any demons
in Marvel Comics
whose name start with a J.
So I just assume that Madison
probably got that part wrong
because you kind of brushes over
a lot of what happened.
Like, yeah, there was fire dimension.
there was a good looking demon that I sold
my soul to is all fine.
no big deal.
He's just going to steal my soul and
the souls of all the people that I love.
If I told too many people about this,
Because this is Wong.
We're dealing with Doctor
Strange mythology from the comics.
Obviously there had been setting up
a lot of more supernatural stuff
just in the MCU in general,
heading on the path
to introducing characters
like Ghost Writer
I believe the actual dimension
that she was sent to
is the same dimension that you see
Doctor Strange in American Chavez
traveling through
as they go through the multiverse
look in the background,
it looks kind of like this.
And it looks a little bit
like Mephisto dimension in the comics to
but that's basically
the references that they're going for.
Like, okay, yeah,
we're going for a Ghost Rider stuff here.
the actual opening scene
that the episode starts
with that metal cover in the Magician
Donnie Blaze pretending
to use magic with a little bit
of real magic thrown in there.
One of the reasons
why we've been seeing so many Ghost Rider
Easter eggs with all these magic
based storylines like the doctor strange
character is because a long time ago,
Kevin Fiege said
one of the things that excited him
most about the Doctor Strange character
is that it was the pathway to darker
stories in the supernatural characters.
He said doing the supernatural stories
through the doctor Strange movies
is the major reason
why now they can do the Blade movie
and they have a justification
to logically explain how vampires
can exist in the MCU alongside
Captain America and Iron Man.
The other characters
What are the reasons why I haven't done
a new blade video in a while
but the movie
that they're making right now
with Mahershala Ali, it is
because
they completely changed the script.
So it's a completely different story
that doesn't involve Kit Harington's
Black Knight character quite as much,
but it does involve the Ebony blade.
So part of that is meant to explain
Blade's appearance during that Eternals
Post-Credits scene. Like,
why would you have him there?
It'll mostly be to pay off
all the ebony blade stuff.
but is bringing it back around
to the Ghost Rider character.
He's a character you could totally use in
darker Disney Plus
series or future supernatural movies
like The Blade sequels.
in fact,
talking more about the Wandavision
Doctor Strange two connections.
If you watched Agents of Shield,
the Ghost Rider
character, The Spirit of Vengeance
already has a deep connection
to the things that are going on
in those stories
through the Darkhold itself,
But you all remember the Mephisto jokes.
The funnier connection here,
just because of all the Mephisto jokes
that were going around during Wandavision
is that Mephisto, the character,
was actually the person in the comics
who bonded the Spirit of Vengeance
to Johnny Blaze in the first place.
that doesn't mean
that Mephisto is going to suddenly show up
when Ghost Rider shows up in the MCU.
Eventually they changed the comic book
stories all the time in their weird
considerations about what they can
and can't do inside China.
I know there's always a question
about that,
the actual surprise is that
they're supposed to introduce a version
of Mephisto in the Ironheart series
of all places in it's
because they're dealing with the balance
of magic versus technology.
Anthony Ramos is playing the hood
during that from Marvel Comics
and supposedly
he'll be dealing with Mephisto and Agatha
from Coven of Chaos
like he wants to work for Agatha.
But supposedly
Mephisto is also trying to manipulate him.
supposedly is going to be played
by Sacha Baron Cohen of all people.
So I don't know what it's going
to look like
when they eventually get to that series,
but we probably won't find out
until next year at some point.
as for who
they would get to play their new version
of Ghost Rider
in the MCU, new version of Johnny Blaze,
I know a lot of people would love to see
Keanu Reeves be their new version
of Johnny Blaze.
right around the time that Avengers
Endgame was coming out.
Kevin Feige did admit
that they were meeting with him
about a project in the MCU,
but he also said that they met with Keanu
Reeves during every big Marvel phase,
just about new projects
that he might be a fit for
and which characters he was interested in.
And the reason
why you haven't seen him in the MCU
yet playing a characters
is because they haven't
found the right character for him yet that
he connects with on a fundamental level.
but everyone let me know in the comments
who do you want to be the new version
of Johnny Blaze Ghost Rider
when he eventually does
show up in a new Marvel project?
They did have a Ghost Rider TV show
they were going to do with the Robbie
Ray is Virgin from Agents of Shield, who's
going to be like a spinoff
with his version of the character.
but when Kevin Feige took over
all the Marvel television shows,
they basically canceled
that Ghost Rider TV show.
in other way, Gabriel Luna talks about it,
the actor,
he says he doesn't expect
to ever come back as that character.
one of the bombers about that, too,
is that they were actually going
to do the Marvel Netflix defenders thing.
But for darker characters
like Ghost Writer,
they were going to do a team-up show
called Adventures into Fear,
and they were going to face
the Lilith character.
She was going to be like the main
overarching villain
Sounds like
it could have been pretty cool,
but Marvel's Helstrom
would have been a big crossover with that.
And that wound up
being a pretty lackluster series.
So I don't know
if we dodged a bullet on that
or if it could have been pretty cool.
I guess we'll never know.
so it does sound like when they introduce
a new Ghost Rider,
it'll be a completely new version
of the character
with a totally different actor.
But if we hear any more news
about Ghost Writer,
of course I'll do more videos about him.
Just in general,
any version of the character in the MCU.
The next big upcoming
Marvel series will be Loki season
two episodes starting in October.
Is that really supernatural connected?
It's mostly connected to all the Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty stuff,
there is a minor connection to the doctor
strange character
like he is a supernatural character,
but not a lot of supernatural stuff
happening in Loki.
What's happening in Doctor
Strange three though, is that
they'll culminate all the incursions right
before of interest.
Five It's like the last movie
before Avengers five
So there's like a loose connection
between what's happening in Loki
with the incursions in Doctor Strange.
Three incursions,
while you wait for everything.
Click here for my Ahsoka Episode
3 trailer video and click here for
that Doctor Strange 3 video to learn
what's going on in that movie.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!